Tom Styer the billionaire investor and
activist who spent millions advocating
for the impeachment of President Trump
is launching a campaign to take his job
he joins a field of 24 other candidates
seeking the Democratic nomination for
president after previously saying he
would not run as part of our continuing
series the road to 2020 he joins us for
his first national television interview
since announcing his candidacy
Tom Steyer good morning welcome Anthony
nice to see you what changed you weren't
in this race in January you specifically
said no I'm not running now you are
actually what I said specifically was I
was not running then because I felt at
that point I had a responsibility to
push the impeachment of mr. Trump we had
6 million people who'd signed our
petition we were still a lonely voice in
the wilderness saying he's the most
corrupt president in history he's unfit
for the office he's dangerously mayor
are you giving up that campaign to
denote that I'm going to continue to
fund that but I believe we've won that
argument I think everybody in DC
including Republicans realizes that what
we were saying for 20 months before
people came around to it is now obvious
and true there's still a question about
whether it happens but I felt as if
watching that for the last six months
and pushing it was a profound failure of
government because everybody understands
he should be impeached at this point
it's a question whether will happen and
I also watch this campaign and I felt as
if I couldn't sleep because to me the
biggest question facing the United
States is not what we should do but how
are we going to break the corrupt
stranglehold that corporations have on
our government and how are we actually
gonna get done things that the American
people want how are we going to return
power to the American people that is the
question in front of us today I didn't
feel it was being addressed let's talk
about what's in your win column you
poured 120 million dollars into the
mid-turn some would say you you won the
house back for the Democrats millions in
the campaigns against Big Oil against
Big Tobacco against corporate tax
loopholes why is a hundred million
dollars running for president money well
spent well Michelle I don't think it's
about the money
for the last ten years I've been trying
to push power back to the people of the
United States to retake the government
from what I think of as a corporate
takeover that's taken place over the
last 40 years and that includes those
propositions where we went around the
Legislature's to go directly to get
people's votes there this is a
continuation as far as I'm concerned of
the grassroots efforts that I've led for
the last 10 years including propositions
including registration including
doubling the turnout of young people in
the swing districts last year to retake
the House of Representatives this is
about retaking the democracy from the
corrupt corporate power that is
determining what happens in Washington
DC hearing you say that first of all
surprising given your stature
financially and in your history but also
interesting because Elizabeth Warren
Bernie Sanders would say that's my
campaign right other candidates as well
and then when it comes to climate change
which is another issue for you
there are numerous candidates including
jay Inslee who are taking on that issue
so what makes you different and can you
be different enough to qualify for a
debate with 1% of the poll well Tony let
me say this I'm an outsider I have been
doing this successfully beating the oil
companies that tobacco companies closing
tax loopholes from the outside for 10
years I don't believe that this failed
government is going to be reformed from
the inside I believe it's a question of
coming from the outside and doing what
I've been doing for the last 10 years
going directly to the people because I
think that we can see that Washington
has been unable to reform itself isn't
it going to take somebody who's got a
different perspective and a different
history and has been doing it for 10
years success something we want to get
some some quick yes or no answers if you
would all disclosure we actually went to
school together but here here some of
the bigger questions that have emerged
on the campaign trail are are these
issues do you support proposals for free
college yes I now every one of these
questions has a lot of nuance to it
understood there is no question in my
mind that our we are under in
vesting in the education of young people
including in college and whether I go
along exactly what senator Sanders exact
proposal is a different question
understood the idea of us providing
quality public education from pre-k
through college and including lifelong
skills training is something I
absolutely support yes or no would your
insurance plan provide coverage for
undocumented immigrants and so the short
answer is gonna be yes but once again I
want to talk about something broader
which is this we have a failed
immigration system we should have
comprehensive immigration reform which
is a classic thing that this government
has been able to unable to do for
decades so in that context what are you
supposed to do with people who are part
of society live here mm-hmm contribute
to society and yet are somehow under the
radar are living in the shadows they're
a part of society so we're doing yes or
no plus I guess this is the classic
thing you can ask a question that has a
million yes one more do you support
reparations for the descendants of
slaves and where I have gone on that
we're gone that is we should do a study
to go back and see what that means but
the other answer if I had to give yes or
no so maybe no no let me let me answer
that more clearly time you got it we
have a society where people don't start
at the same starting line and that has
been something that has been built in
through centuries of unfairness and
injustice and exactly the best way to
address that as a society is a subject
of real study but whether to address
that as a society is not a question of
course we need to address that that's
why I said a study because this is
complicated
it's got to be perceived by Americans is
to be fair across the board mm-hmm and
it's we've got to accept the idea that
this is a society which is not treated
people equally for centuries are you in
time are you expecting to make the next
debate I my edited method races I don't
think I can make July because I'm just
too late
okay but I'm gonna take very seriously
getting on the debate stage in September
right Tom Steyer and thank you so much
for being with us nice to see you